the reality is i'm an idiot like and i'm
not being
i'm not being flip about it like i don't
understand very complicated things
and so i ask a lot of questions so that
the person who's telling me
something complicated who's talking in
terms as if i understand them sure
finance or neuroscience i don't know
what you're talking about right and i
ask enough questions just so that i
understand it
so is what you're saying this no that's
what i'm saying well what are you so
i i we're most i mean i'll give you a
perfect example so a long time ago i had
a client
they were a a
public company and uh they brought me on
um to do some work for them but the
the they invited me to sit in on a
meeting
from the consultant that they had hired
um
and so all the c-level executives and me
and this consultant was giving a
presentation about something wrong this
is junior marketing
this is when i had my little marketing
company and every all the ce level
executives sitting there nodding and
taking notes on the on the you know on
the powerpoint that they had printed up
in front of them and i had it as
well and i didn't understand a freaking
word of it yeah right i was like looking
around like yeah i'm
r and i and so i'd raise my hand and say
i'm really really sorry
i know i'm the only person in this room
without an mba but
this doesn't make sense like you say a
plus b equals c but
based on your logic a plus b equals d
can you just say it again please
i'm really i'm really sorry to slow the
meeting down everybody you know and you
could see the consultant getting
frustrated with me and would try and
explain it again i said i'm
so sorry and one by one all the c-level
executives
said yeah i don't understand it either
now if the idiot hadn't spoken up
yeah and said i don't understand they
all would have nodded their heads yeah
for fear of looking stupid
because they don't understand yeah and
it would have they would have paid a lot
of money
for a document they didn't understand
and they would never have used it would
have sat on a shelf
um and it's it's because i'm i'm okay
being the idiot like
that's why i'm not being flipped i'm
okay everybody in the room going ugh
because i have to ask questions until i
understand it but the reality is is once
i can get
to the point where i understand it i can
get it so simple that i understand it
and i can say it in simple terms that
means other people understand it too
yeah yeah so it's there's a lot of value
being the idiot